how much an artist's work boils down to
just play market that's a that's a good
question how much really hard to say a
percentage and I think that what we've
seen is that some more than others and
you know sometimes artists are
criticized within the artist community
from marketing too much which is another
issue that we have to get over the
social proof for creative people is not
at the same level of the social proof of
Baker's right you know if bankers have a
good year we know this from Wall Street
I've gone out to dinner with them where
they order five hundred dollar bottles
of something and pass them around their
social proof it they clap each other on
the back and they're really happy that
they had a million-dollar year or a
million-dollar month in the creative
community if someone has a
million-dollar month other creeps people
feel envious jealous angry say maybe you
know you're not really the artist that
you once were so we kind of have to get
around that and so the the line between
selling and marketing and success in
marketing is a blurry and difficult line
but i would rather recast your question
if i may i think that a lot of an artist
success maybe ninety percent of an
artist success is offering the work so
if we don't think about it as marketing
we think about it is offering i think a
lot of the financial success or public
awareness success is in being able to
offer the work and just say hey I made
this thing I think it's really beautiful
I think you will too here it is and if
artists can't offer their work they
can't really receive anything back for
part of what offering part of what goes
with offering also is the ability to
know who you're offering to so one of
the things that I like to train people
in is knowing who
your audience is and unique you can't
reach everybody we don't have 850 or 200
million dollar studio marketing budget
to blake at the airwaves and the cable
stations and the youtube channels and
every other place so we get like lots of
paid commercials we can't afford paid
commercials right we have to get our
word out through word of mouth or a very
very minimal marketing budget so we have
to be super targeted we have to be hyper
targeted we have to be like like snipers
like knowing exactly who our audience is
and so knowing who your audience is who
you're making your work for is one of
the keys to successfully offering the
work to those people
you